>> Laura: WHY IT IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUDDENLY WORRIED
ABOUT SAVING JOBS IN CHINA?
TRUMP MAY EASE OFF THE U.S. BAN
ON EXPORTS TO CHINESE TELECOM
MAKER AND BIG GIANT ZTE TWEETING
TOO MANY JOBS IN CHINA LAWS.
HOWEVER THE HEADS OF THE FBI AND
CIA HAVE WARNED AMERICANS BY
BUYING ZTE PHONES BECAUSE THEY
ARE CONSIDERED A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK.
IS SENATOR MARCO RUBIO SAYS IT'S
CRAZY TO HELP ZTE.
I SPOKE WITH HIM JUST A SHORT
TIME AGO.
>> SENATOR, YOU HAVE BEEN
WRITING AND SPEAKING A LOT ABOUT
THE CHINA THREAT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS AND THIS REALLY
TOOK ME BY A COMPLETE SURPRISE
TODAY.
WITH THIS SEEMING REVERSAL OF
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS A VERY COMMON
SENSE APPROACH TO THE CHINESE
TELECOM GIANT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TONIGHT?
THE WHITE HOUSE SEEMED TO TRY TO
BACK OFF A LITTLE BIT IN
REACTION TODAY.
CHINA WILL HAVE TO MAKE
CONCESSIONS ON ITS PAST
CHEATING, FRANKLY, BUT WHAT IS
YOUR REACTION?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DON'T FEEL
BAD FOR THESE COMPANIES BECAUSE
FRANKLY THEY HAVE BENEFITED
GREATLY AND CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
GREAT GREATLY FROM THE THEFT AND
INTELLECTUAL CHEATING.
WHICH IS WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
DOES ON BEHALF OF THEIR
COMPANIES.
IT WAS REALLY CONCERNING HIS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS IS ONE OF THE
TEN OR 12 INDUSTRIES THAT CHINA
TENDS TO DOMINATE THE WORLD AND
SO TO BE SELLING AMERICAN
TECHNOLOGY TO ZTE IS GOING TO
ALLOW THEM TO GET IT AND REVERSE
ENGINEER IT AND THEN THEY WILL
MAKE IT THEMSELVES THAN THEY
WON'T NEED US ANYMORE AND THEY
DO THAT IN EVERY INDUSTRY.
THIS WAS NOT A TRADE ISSUE.
IT WAS BECAUSE THEY GOT CAUGHT
HELPING NORTH KOREA AND HELPING
IRAN EVADE SANCTIONS AND THEY
WERE PUNISHED FOR IT.
BUT FRANKLY WE SHOULD NOT BE IN
THE BUSINESS -- ZTE SHOULD NOT
BE OPERATING UNFETTERED IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO AMERICAN
TECHNOLOGY.
>> Laura: SENATOR, THERE'S
ALWAYS THIS TENSION BETWEEN THE
NATIONAL SECURITY SIDE OF THINGS
AND THE ECONOMIC SIDE OF THINGS.
IT SEEMS THAT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
TRIANGULATE ON THIS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS CONCERN ABOUT
FARMERS AND THE SOYBEAN TARIFF
THAT CHINA HAS THREATENED TO PUT
ON THEM.
ALSO WITH THE UPCOMING TALKS
WITH NORTH KOREA, WITHOUT A
DOUBT CHINA HAS PLAYED SOME ROLE
IN FACILITATING PERHAPS HOW
WE'VE GOTTEN TO THIS POINT THIS
FAR.
DO YOU TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS YOU JUDGE THIS?
>> NO, BECAUSE WITHOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY YOU HAVE NO ECONOMY AND
IN THE CASE OF CHINA, PART OF
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT IS
THEY INTEND TO WIPE OUT
UNITED STATES INDUSTRIES IN TEN
KEY SECTORS.
IT'S CALLED MADE IN CHINA 2025.
THEY HAVE TELEGRAPHED IT VERY
CLEARLY.
THEY INTEND TO DOMINATE THE
WORLD IN THESE TEN INDUSTRIES
AND ONE OF THE WAY THEY DO IT IS
THEY TAKE AMERICAN SECRETS, THE
EITHER SPY ON US AND STEAL THEM
OR THEY GET AMERICAN COMPANIES
TO DO BUSINESS WITH THEM AND
THEN THEY TAKE WHATEVER IT IS WE
INVENTED AND THEY LEARN HOW TO
MAKE IT THEMSELVES EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO UNDER
THE LAW AND THEN THEY GET RID OF
US AND THEN THEY START COMPETING
WITH US, SUBSIDIZED BY THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
YOU DO THAT IN ENOUGH INDUSTRIES
AND IT BECOMES A NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT AND THEN IN THE
CASE OF ZTE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS, THESE ARE
DEVICES THAT COULD BE
THEORETICALLY USED, NOT
THEORETICALLY, THEY CAN BE USED
WITHOUT ANY COURT ORDERS OR
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE.
IF THIS WAS A FARM DISPUTE
THAT'S ONE THING, BUT THIS IS A
DIRECT THREAT TO OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY AND OUR ECONOMIC
WELL-BEING, WHICH ARE
INTERRELATED.
>> MARKEL, CHUCK SCHUMER TODAY
SAID AND I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR SO
LONG SO I JUST CALLED YOU MARCO.
SORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> JUST DON'T SAY PAULO.
>> Laura: SENATOR RUBIO,
CHUCK SCHUMER TWEETED OUT KIND
OF AN AGREEMENT WITH YOU AND
MYSELF.
HE WAS PRETTY HARSH, HE SAID
MAKE CHINA GREAT AGAIN.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT
DONALD TRUMP WANTS -- IS
INTERESTED IN MAKING CHINA GREAT
AGAIN OR WOULD PURPOSELY HARM
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY INTEREST
BY DOING SOME TYPE OF DEAL WITH
CHINA ON THIS DO YOU?
>> NO.
I DON'T.
I JUST THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE TRIPPING OVER THERE.
EVERY DAY SOME GROUP OF CEOs
COMES MARCHING INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND TRIES TO TALK
THE PRESIDENT DOWN FROM THE
STRONG STAND THAT HE HAS TAKEN
ON CHINA.
THERE'S A LOT OF VOICES.
PERHAPS EVEN SOME PEOPLE WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION THAT WANT TO
BACK DOWN A LITTLE BIT ON THE
CHINA THING.
THIS CONFRONTATION WITH CHINA IS
BY FAR THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
FACING THIS COUNTRY ON A GLOBAL
SCALE.
THIS IS GOING TO DEFINE THE NEXT
80 YEARS.
THEY INTEND TO REPLACE US.
>> Laura: I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH YOU.
THE BUSINESS INTEREST, I WOULD
SAY IF GOLDMAN SACHS IS HAPPY
ABOUT SOMETHING REGARDING CHINA
I'M USUALLY NOT HAPPY.
THIS IS ONE ON ANOTHER ISSUE ON
THE TAX BILL.
THIS IS WHAT YOU WERE QUOTED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AS SAYING
ABOUT THE G.O.P. TAX BILL.
YOU SAID IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE FLOWING TO
CORPORATIONS, IT WAS IMPORTANT
TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK AND DO
MORE FOR WORKING FAMILIES, AGAIN
IN REFERENCE TO THE TAX BILL,
OTHERWISE THE MESSAGE IS WHAT IT
HAS BEEN FOR 25 YEARS FOR BOTH
PARTIES, THAT IS WHEN PUSH COMES
TO SHOVE, WE WANT YOUR VOTE BUT
WE ARE NOT ALL THAT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE WORKING CLASS.
THIS IS WHAT TRISH REAGAN SAID.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE A GUY WHO
LIKE TO LOWER TAXES.
LOWER TAXES ENABLE PEOPLE TO
KEEP MORE OF THEIR MONEY.
BUT NOW PERHAPS BECAUSE IT'S
BENEFICIAL TO HIM POLITICALLY
HE'S TRYING TO DIVIDE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE IS
REFERRING TO.
I AM FOR LOWER TAXES.
I THINK THE WHOLE DEBATE BEGAN
WITH THIS.
WE HAVE A CORPORATE TAX RATE OF
35.
THE REPUBLICAN BILL LOWERED IT
TO 20.
I SAID WHY DON'T WE LOWER IT TO
21, WHICH IS STILL MASSIVE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT APPLE AND
GOOGLE, THESE MULTINATIONAL --
NOT TALK ABOUT S CORPORATIONS,
YOUR EVERYDAY SMALL BUSINESS,
MIDSIZE BUSINESS.
TALKING ABOUT BIG, MULTINATIONAL
BIG CORPORATIONS FOR THE MOST
PART.
I SAID INSTEAD OF LOWERING TO
20, LET'S LOWERED TO 21, STILL A
DRAMATIC CUT AND ACTUALLY SAID
20.9 AND LET'S USE THAT .9 TO
FULLY EXPAND THE CHILD TAX
CREDIT FOR WORKING FAMILIES.
IN MY ARGUMENT WAS THAT .9 WAS
BETTER IN THE HANDS OF THESE
WORKERS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
HURT BY ALL THE CHANGES IN THE
ECONOMY.
>> Laura: BUT IT'S OVER.
I SEE WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM,
BUT THAT'S OVER AND NOW WE HAVE
THE MIDTERMS.
IT'S LIKE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO BE
UNIFIED ON THIS ISSUE AND I CAN
SEE THE ARGUMENT -- WITH ALL
THAT TO HANG TOGETHER HERE ON
THIS TAX BILL.
IT'S WHAT WE HAVE.
IT'S NOT PERFECT.
A LOT MORE I WANT TO, WE DIDN'T
GET IT.
>> IT IS WHAT IT IS AND ON THAT
IT'S A POSITIVE.
THE ISSUE IS THE ATTITUDE.
THE ATTITUDE THAT SOME PEOPLE
HAD TOWARD THAT CHILD TAX
CREDIT.
IT'S BETTER OFF IN THE HANDS OF
THESE BIG CORPORATIONS THAN IT
IS IN THE HANDS OF A WORKING
FAMILY.
THAT ATTITUDE IS GOING TO BE
ONGOING AND WE CANNOT CONTINUE
BECAUSE WORKING PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN CRUSHED OVER
THE LAST 20 YEARS BY ALL THESE
CHANGES.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: THAT'S FOR SURE.
WE WILL SEE NEXT YEAR THE FULL
FORCE OF THE TAX BILL KICK IN
WHEN THEY HAVE TO FILE THEIR
TAXES UNDER THIS NEW REGIME IN
2019.
SENATOR RUBIO, BEFORE WE LET YOU
GO, BIG BLOCKBUSTER STORY TODAY
IN THE HILL.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THE STORY
MUELLER HAD NOT DISCLOSED THIS
BEFORE HE WAS NAMED OF COURSE
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> FIRST OF ALL, BOB LEVINSON IS
A FLORIDIAN, THE FAMILY IS FROM
FLORIDA.
I WANTED TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE WITH A LOT TO GET HIM
HOME AND WE MET WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT HIS CASE.
UNFAIRLY DETAINED, HIS CASE WAS
FORGOTTEN AT THE END OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHEN
THEY'RE CUTTING DEALS WITH IRAN.
THIS IS A MAN WHO SERVED POTOMAC
SERVED OUR COUNTRY AND WAS
UNJUSTLY KIDNAPPED.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT I'M
SAYING, A RUSSIAN OLIGARCH USED
$25 MILLION ACCORDING TO
MULTIPLE SOURCES OF HIS OWN
MONEY TO GET THIS GUY OUT.
>> SO I'M ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE SO I WANT TO BE
CAREFUL ABOUT CONFIRMING OR
DENYING ANY SORT OF MEDIA
ARTICLES BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE WITH
REGARD TO THIS, I'M NOT
CONFIRMING IT.
I SAW THE SAME ARTICLE.
SUFFICE IT TO SAY THAT
MR. MUELLER IS IN BOSTON,
CONDUCTING THIS INVESTIGATION.
IF THERE IS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AT SOME POINT IT WOULD
JEOPARDIZE THE INVESTIGATION.
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE FACTS.
I THINK WE WILL SEE AS THIS
THING ROLLS FORWARD AND AS HE
BRINGS OUT -- THIS INVESTIGATION
HAS TO END AT SOME POINT.
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
WHO HE WENT AFTER AND WHO HE
DIDN'T AND THEN ASK THESE
QUESTIONS.
BUT WE SHOULD WAIT UNTIL THAT
MOMENT ARRIVES.
BUT ON THIS PARTICULAR CASE WE
HAVE THAT ARTICLE.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW QUITE FRANKLY
HOW ANY OF THAT IS CLASSIFIED OR
NOT AT THIS POINT.
SO I PERSONALLY CAUTIOUS.
I'M TRYING TO BE EVASIVE.
I DON'T WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE
HERE AND GO BEYOND WHERE I
SHOULD.
TWO FIGHTS TO SAY FOR PURPOSES
OF AN INVESTIGATION BOB MUELLER
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FINISH HIS
WORK AND THEN -- IT HAS TO END
AT SOME POINT AND HE WILL BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT IT ALL AND SAY
WHY DID YOU DO THIS OR NOT DO
THAT?
>> Laura: I THINK WE ARE GOING
TO LEARN A LOT MORE ABOUT THIS
IN THE DAYS TO COME BUT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR VOICE ON